a hard-working tax-paying kid raisin
church-going citizen of this country and
if I work hard all day long want to go
home and relax with the joint that is my
civil liberty what is your interest in
Hempfest you're a regular here what why
do you come every year well I just think
marijuana should not be criminal I'm not
here to promote marijuana I just think
it's a civil liberty if people want to
use it there really is a matter of
principle about this and I thought about
it and I thought I am really into travel
you know I'm a travel writer I've spent
a third of my adult life just traveling
I just love going places and to me high
is a place and I really treasure that
and when I want to go there I want to go
there I
I don't need my government to give me a
passport for that place I started
speaking out when it was pretty scary
and I spoke out because a lot of people
agree with this and we're tired of when
united states embracing just one more
ridiculous lie and I could speak out
with no risk of being voted out of
office or losing my job because nobody
needs to vote for me and I'm
self-employed so has has your
pro-legalization position has it
affected your public personality or your
audience at all I don't really pay much
attention to that I just do what I think
is true and this is a matter of truth
you know I get a lot of people that read
about what I think about marijuana they
say I know what you think about pot and
we're not going to use your guidebooks
anymore and we're not gonna take any of
your Europe tours and all I can think is
Europe is gonna be more fun without you
alright what's the best country for
dealing with marijuana at this point
well I don't know what the best country
for dealing with marijuana is but what I
try to do is inject a European
sensibility into discussion here in
United States Europe has it's drug
problems just like we have our drug
problems and you can abuse marijuana you
can you know you a lot of people argue
it's addictive certainly not for kids
anybody who's driving intoxicated by
anything so you have the book thrown at
them these are just common sense sort of
how you live in a community but in
Europe they take the crime out of the
situation they take the violence and the
money out of and they treat it as a
health problem and education challenge
ten years ago in Portugal they decided
to legalize the consumption of all drugs
all drugs
and I just interviewed the their drug
czar who wrote that law for my radio
show and you can see it on my website if
you're going to hear it but they said
after ten years now they have done a
review of the effectiveness because
there's a little scary you know to
legalize the consumption of all drugs
and they've decided after ten years even
people who were opposed to that use has
not gone up they took the crime out of
the equation and now they can deal with
it in a smart pragmatic harm-reduction
kind of way pretty good what they've
done is they've made marijuana boring
it's no longer quite so sexy you know
and it's just there for people who want
it it's really quite amazing a lot of
Americans think there's a whole
reservoir of people out there would that
would just love to ruin their lives by
smoking pot if only it was legal these
people are clueless anybody who wants to
smoke pot I think does and they just
have to be criminals to do it and I'm
convinced if you legalize marijuana
tomorrow once in in Washington state use
might spike a little bit it would settle
back down to about where it is today and
it would just be a non-issue that's what
it is near a non-issue we're not talking
pro drugs here we're talking civil
liberty if somebody wants to smoke pot
in a mature adult way just recreational
I believe that's a civil liberty now you
know if you're gonna smoke pot and go
drive your car and hurt somebody that's
not a civil liberty so the main thing is
that there's 800,000 people arrested
every year in our country for simple
marijuana possession now these aren't
rich white guys these are poor people
and black people and people who don't
really can't handle a bump in the road
like that for the rest of their lives
they've got a record a criminal record
and that's a real tragic thing for our
society there are so many reasons to get
smart about marijuana laws I'm not
saying be soft on drugs or hard on drugs
we need to be smart on drugs like the
Europeans are it's not an easy thing
drug about drug abuse is a serious
problem
but we can do better here in the United
States and to me that's very exciting
and a very good starting point is what
we're doing right here at Hempfest
raising awareness of the fact that
marijuana should not be illegal